entrepreneurship is hard we read all
about the successes but we have to
understand that there are many more
people who never get over the hurdle
when they start the process like this
Stanford embark is designed to help
people get over that hurdle
Stanford embarked is an online
experience for aspiring entrepreneurs
and early-stage entrepreneurs what
embark exists to do is to provide the
support for an individual who struggles
to deal with the difficulties of making
change happen our goal was to bring
together the faculty who offer structure
in the classroom and founders and people
who come through these programs and gone
through the entrepreneurial experience
resources that an entrepreneur would
need to ask an answer a particular set
of questions stanford embark is not a
course embark is like a companion but is
a set of activities that helps you to
zero in on the right question to ask and
provides you with suggestions on how to
answer it in our research one of the
phrases we heard that we responded to
was the idea that anything for
entrepreneurs needs to be radically
practical it would have immediate
application for an entrepreneur one of
the things we begin with is a
self-assessment we then offer an
organizing framework that we call the
startup canvas there are basically four
quadrants one has to do with the problem
that you're solving another the solution
that you provide
how are you going to go to market and
the last is will you be able to make
money the speaker series component is an
opportunity for people to connect and
hear about real experiences that relates
to the material that you'll be exposed
to on the mark platform what we hope is
that people can use embark will consider
themselves parts of this growing
Stanford community of aspiring and
successful entrepreneurs throughout the
world
[Music]
you